MBC's proposed Zener reboot may have
been scrapped by the studio in 2017 but
that doesn't mean fans of the warrior
princess can still get their hit
afterall iconic zener actor Lucy Lawless
is still other and she's been very busy
indeed here's all the great stuff that's
happened for the Xena star since the end
of her breakout nineties role having
forged her career as one of the greatest
cult icons of our time Lala's has since
managed to maintain that status by
pairing intestines of beloved shows in
2006 she starred as an FBI agent
attempting to extract some sensitive
information from Neptune savviest
teenage detective in Veronica Mars and a
year later she enjoyed a guest
appearance on Curb Your Enthusiasm as a
version of herself stuck on an
excruciatingly ly bad date with Larry
David Wallace has also enjoyed a number
of other unexpected guest appearances
which have included comedies such as
Flight of the Conchords dramas like top
of the lake and Burn Notice
and comic book adaptations like agents
of shield Murray stop shaking her hand
for years many die-hard fans of Xena
have maintained that the rumored romance
between Xena and Gabrielle amounted to
far more than just innuendo and queer
subtext and in 2003 Marlys was happy to
confirm that the two were definitely gay
the actor said it wasn't just that Xena
was bisexual and kind of like a gal pal
and had kind of fooled around sometimes
it was nope they're married man as well
as enjoying an appearance on the
groundbreaking LGBT drama the l-word
Mullis has attended various celebrations
and events and proud public supports of
the LGBT community in 2017 she even
received the ally of the Year award at
the 2017 Australian LGBTI Awards and in
2018 attended the inaugural New Zealand
LGBTI awards ceremony as they're proud
ambassador while speaking about the
influence Sina had in providing
visibility and encouragement to the
lesbian community
Lala's describes ena fans as being a
force for good that she's immensely
grateful for Wallace said nobody else
outside of our world is going to
understand or appreciate that but I know
and they know that that was a profound
experience for all of us anyone with a
fond memory of the groundbreaking
musical episodes of Xena will or
be aware that lawless is kind of an
amazing singer what you may not be aware
of however it's just how much Lala's
loves being a musician in 2009 the actor
was a contestant on the Australian
singing competition Celebrity duets
where she sang kapa said such musical
legends as Dionne Warwick and Bonnie
Tyler having had a background in musical
theatre Lalas has returned to her roots
by leading a show called pleasure-dome
the musical billed as a dirty urban
musical with a queer love story at a
score the campaign tea set musical is
produced by a husband and focuses on a
female business owner played by lawless
standing up against a bigoted
businessman lawless told the New Zealand
Herald that the musical feels more
timely than ever today since the LGBT
community is under threat like it hasn't
been since the 70s in her opinion
however the visibility that shows such
as Pleasure Dome gives the LGBT
community is the answer she said people
that love and support and accept the
LGBT community need to band together and
show that there are more of us than
there are other detractors we have to
win this for the sake of everybody
fans of the quirky cult filmmaker Sam
Raimi will likely know that he prefers
to work with the same people time and
again and while it might not have much
of a screen presence in Rainey's
productions as actors like bruce
campbell robert suffered shares a number
of producer credits with Raimi the two
have worked together on projects
including The Grudge don't breathe the
Evil Dead franchise and of course Xena
Warrior Princess tappets and lawless
obviously made a terrific impression on
one another
occurs in 1998 the star of Sina went on
to marry the producer they remained
married to this day and still work as
creative collaborators in 2011 lawless
appeared in Raimi and suffered Spartacus
series before snagging a supporting role
than ash vs. Evil Dead in 2015 even
though the actor confessed to being less
than a fan of the original movie when it
was first released lawless made the
surprising confession in an interview
with Rotten Tomatoes where she admitted
that she was so outraged by the Evil
Dead as a 17 year old that she marched
out of the movie after the infamous tree
scene she said I was so mortally
offended that I got up and stomped out
saying these people are misogynist and
sick and that movie's awful twelve years
later I was married to one of them trick
of fate though Lala's has enjoyed a
diverse career since leaving Xena it's
also easy to imagine
the actor may have been typecast in a
very specific type of role a strong
ferocious woman who typically shows up
in period pieces and the actor has
indeed returned to such roles time and
again in productions like Salem and
Spartacus and although she's clearly
proud of these roles according to a
conversation with interview magazine
these tough woman characters on the ones
that interests are the most crucially
lawless is interested in seeking out
characters who allow her to reflect on
her own life and identity and from the
sounds of it much of that has little to
do with being a warrior princess lawless
told interview magazine as an artist you
want to be able to explore facets of
yourself the roles I am proudest of are
the ones where I get to be a stain on
the wall I like to play women who are
not strong at all because there's
certainly plenty of myself there is no
kind of a warrior possessing the nerd
cred that she does it made sense when
lawless join the cast of the Battlestar
Galactica reboot in 2005 arriving in the
8th episode of season 2 lawless depicts
Deanna beers a trashy tabloid reporter
for the fleet News Service who is
filming a warts-and-all reports about
the Galactica the episode is to summing
the fun and light-hearted but it comes
with a bombshell at the end that has
been called one of Wallace's most
unexpected TV scenes ever the revelation
appears as a Cylon
truly is a miracle from God considering
mullis's apparent love for philosophy
it's perhaps unsurprising that the
religious aspect of some of the deeper
themes of Battlestar Galactica are what
drew the actor to the show lawless Todd
Galactica TV that she saw the ANA as a
character consumed by the nature and the
philosophy of God and she loved the
characters complex questioning spirits
lawless explained she was a zealot
she was an outlaw she was a betrayer and
yet she saw herself as a great Patriot
in a way by far one of lawless is most
beloved roles since leaving Xena has to
be that of Diane Lewis and Parks and
Recreation the single mother with whom
Nick Offerman's Ron Swanson falls madly
in love and eventually marries a
self-confessed Parks and Rec superfan
the role was a huge win for lawless
lawless only appeared in ten episodes of
the wildly adored comedy between 2012
and 2014 but sir-- character was pivotal
in taking Swanson out of his comfort
zone
Diane transformed run from a surly
bachelor into a surly husband and father
giving the character something he had
never had before on the show a genuinely
healthy romantic relationship lawless
also confessed that Diane is a character
closest to her own personality of anyone
she's ever played on top of that she has
also admitted to being something of an
aficionado for the show who had seen
every episode prior to stepping foot on
set to the point that she was able to
correct Offerman about Parks and Rec
continuity during filming a
self-described Court gold lawless is
something of a true crime fanatic who is
so fascinated with the subject that she
even attends real-life trials whenever
she has the chance as she told The
Associated Press it just teaches you so
much about life and your own society and
justice and about yourself it's really
important that we participate in the
democracy that's a really good way to
hold the justice system to the standards
of the people she has also discussed the
thrill of chatting about trial to the
cops and journalists involved afterwards
and that fascination appears to have led
her to one of her more recent projects
the acorn TV streaming series my life is
murder which CeeCee's closely mirrors
her personal interests and it's probably
no surprise are the characters so
closely aligned of many of Lala's
interests since the star a stated that
creates her Clair Tonkin wrote the role
with her in mind
Lala's told AP news
a lot of me in the character and that's
the advantage of having writers build
something around you I'm a very lucky
woman beyond her acting career lawless
has also demonstrated a firm commitment
to fighting for the environment the Xena
Star is a passionate activist and even
worked with Greenpeace as a climate
ambassador in 2012 clearly the title
wasn't just for show as the star joined
in on some direct action and was
arrested along with seven other
activists after climbing to the top of a
Shell oil drilling ship in opposition of
planned oil drilling operations in the
Arctic at the time Lawler stated that
her reasons for the protests were
logical saying I believe passionately
that renewable energy is the way of the
future we don't have to go to the ends
of the earth to suck out every last drop
of oil instead we need to smarten up and
begin the transition to a clean green
sustainable energy future and right now
that means keeping shell out of the
Arctic during interviews have followed
her arrest lawless remained proud of her
actions and insisted on her celebrity
something she calls a very silly kind of
currency helped to raise visibility and
awareness and the urgent fight against
climate change
lawless later pleaded guilty to
trespassing charges and was ordered by a
New Zealand judge to pay a minor fine
and complete 120 hours of community
service in interviews lawless has stated
that she and her siblings were raised by
their hard-working parents to be what
she calls contributors she told stuff on
the weekends mum and dad would visit
people maybe they were sick or
celebrating their Diamond Jubilee that
sort of thing since leaving Xena is
clear that contributing to communities
and to good causes has continued to be a
great passion of hers over the past
couple of decades lawless has done a
great deal of work for various charities
aiding LGBT people environmental causes
breast cancer research and hiv/aids
causes she even sits on the board of
trustees for the starship Foundation
which provides fundraising efforts for
New Zealand's largest Children's
Hospital and Lawless is altruistic
Nature has long inspired her fans to do
the same in 2007
lawless and her fans set up field a love
week an annual charity drive at the end
of September that encourages fans to
support a charity they care about be it
by donating money supplies or
volunteering speaking device in 2017
lalla suggested it's the thing she's
most proud of in her career thus far she
said people started doing random acts
kindness in their communities rather
than giving to my charity or something
I'm involved in I asked them to go and
do something to enrich their own
communities and we did amazing things
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]